when YouTube is at its peak or when it
says peak engagement its vlogging it's
somebody looking into the camera and in
a very personal way talking about their
experience it's almost somewhere between
Warhol and reality TV and The Truman
Show what is it about that vlog format
that is so compelling in your mind you
know I don't I don't know I mean I don't
find it that compelling I don't want you
to but you do it all the time which I
yours is the vlog format yeah absolutely
I sit and I look in the camera and I
[ __ ] pontificate like everybody else
you watch other people's flock that's
what I mean no I don't find other people
vlogging interesting if I have a choice
to sit down and watch Netflix or HBO or
Game of Thrones or reruns of The Office
or watching YouTube
I'll always pick the prior I'm an old
man are you how old you 38 as of two
weeks ago yeah but but I am at the I'm
so here's an interesting anecdote yeah I
am the oldest millennial like my wife is
a couple years old I mean she's
definitely not a millennial yeah your
and I have a kid who I had when I was 16
and he's the he's the youngest
millennial so right now he's 21 and I'm
38 and I definitely think we're part of
the same generation but I'm on the
oldest end of that and he's our youngest
and that didn't even I say that because
like I still have an affinity for not
the content that I think my audience has
an affinity for not the content that
this Jen's II this younger generation of
me I know but I also think it's I think
it's millennial and Gen Z I think both
of them yeah both have an affinity for
the kind of content that you were
describing and I think you started this
dialogue out by saying why are people
why do people find that interesting yes
and I think the answer to that is we are
so we in society we're so inundated with
content with media these days you're 48
on 38 we were both kids I had
Nickelodeon you may not have had
Nickelodeon I remember when cable came
out I did not grow up a nickel oh no
Mike I grew up with ABC and NBC having
Saturday morning cartoons great cartoons
were something you got to watch
for school or on Saturday so Saturday
morning was for cartoons so perfect
illustration so you had afternoons and
you had Saturdays and I had afternoons
and you know until my parents would make
me turn it off right and I look at
people today I look at me I look around
I look at we're in my office right now
and there are five people in here and
three of the five in here are four of
the five in here four of the six in here
are staring at screens we spend the vast
majority of our time in our days in
front of screens and I think that what
that does in aggregate is it makes you
hyper sensitive to what it is that
you're consuming and I think most of
this is on the subconscious level but it
does make you it makes you very
conscious of what you're consuming what
it is and with that there's so much
[ __ ] in the world of media so much
marketing and advertising and finally a
to pay attention to this and spin in
algorithms that are putting stuff in
front of you that are meant to you know
give you the right amount of do that we
sort of yearn for a sense of something
that's real or true and we have no idea
what to trust and then all of a sudden
there's this kid and she's sitting on
the edge of her bed talking into a
camera that's not very well set up and
15/16 yeah I mean that was that was 2006
Evan but and it turned out that was all
about now I'm talking about those
loggers you were referring to and I
think to a generation that feels
somewhat disenfranchised from the media
that shove down their throat they find
something refreshing in in Felix talking
to camera every day about whatever it is
he's excited about they find something
exciting about learning about the latest
technology from iJustine who's just
sitting in her bedroom recording or
marques Brownlee cuz you watched him
come up you know he's a real person
there's no questioning the source of the
of the voice and I think that's a really
special thing